Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys. This is.
And we are picking back up again with a one shot from the Avengers comics from
Jason, Aaron. This is the,
I guess kind of like the prologue is what it's called from. Enter the Phoenix.
Enter the Phoenix is the current ongoing story in our vendors right now,
where does not covering or wait until it's done and then we'll cover the whole
thing, but this is kind of intriguing.
And the reason why is because I don't really know how I feel about this kind of
change as being introduced here. And really,
I'm not even really sure how I feel about the whole idea of the Phoenix.
And then I'll explain why here in a minute.
But the important thing about this is that this initially picks up with the
woman who would become the first host of the Phoenix force on earth 1 million
years ago, basically kind of like in this, this kind of fire pit, right?
Not necessarily a pit that's actually like on fire,
but like the burnt place is what she calls it.
And the idea behind this is that like a lot of early tribes and a lot of early
history and humanity because humanity in its early days was basically stupid.
Whenever you had beings that looked different or seem different,
they would abandoned them there. And this instance,
this little girl was abandoned in this place because she had red hair and
presumably they considered it an ill omen.
And the result was that they just kind of left her, you know,
left her in this location. Of course, again,
kind of only something that a stupid person would really do.
But the idea is that you have these,
these kind of vultures that seemingly show up with the intention of consuming
her. And then of course,
Wolf show up and then basically saver following that she's actually raised by
wolves. Quite literally. She's raised by Wolf. She's a feral human being,
but it's kind of cool, right? While she's with Wolf, she learns to hunt.
She learns to track.
She learns all of these important things on how to survive out there in the
wilderness and to do what she needs to do in order to make it.
But every so often she would return back to the birth place to try to save
individuals. She could,
if there were people who were left there or something along those lines,
and in one instance where she stumbled across the baby, that was there,
she threw a rocket.
One of the bowsers chased them away only for us to realize it's basically a
psych pops us here. Now in that moment,
she kind of receives this telepathic message from a being that tells her,
like don't be afraid and then kind of escorts her back to effectively a safe
place. Now this individual is never actually given, uh,
never really given a name here instead.
He's very much presented to us as a kind of Charles Xavier character, right?
This guy who basically, you know, kind of existed, you know,
1 million years ago when mutants were first starting to pop up.
And then the result was that he kind of grabbed them and then took them,
brought them this location and just kind of helped them to learn how to harness
and use their powers. Now,
this is where things are changing a lot over the course of, of Marvel comics,
really with Jason, Aaron, and the Avengers,
specifically with the idea of Newtons and the reason why is because when you,
whenever you go through the history of the mutant population and Marvel comics,
what you have here is you have, uh,
have a woman by the name of saline and saline was born about 10,000 years. Uh,
well,
really about 17,000 years ago during the high Borean age and is by and large
considered to be the first meeting to exist,
which is to say a person who had a gene that activated and then in turn gave her
powers. Now, the idea is that with saline, she's technically an external, um,
basically meaning that she has to, she's essentially a mortal,
but then the important thing to understand is that in Marvel,
whether you look at, uh, look at saline, you look at proton mutants.
So people like Gabriel Shepherd, whatever the case is,
Munis did not exist before 10,000 years ago. There are things like the,
the Serafin and CI RFM,
but they're largely considered to be extra dimensional beings, right?
I guess they're kind of mutans, but not really.
But traditional mutants were just to say somebody who's gene manifests when
they, when they become a teenager, whether through stress or through puberty,
they didn't exist before 10,000 years ago.
This is Jason Aaron kind of making it,
making it up and saying actually they did.
But the idea here is that with her being in this location,
it basically gives her the ability to live among her own time, right?
People who have powers now, we're not explicitly told this girl has powers,
but this really seems to come into play when she starts getting these headaches.
Now at 10 years old, this is when her body starts changing.
And that's usually around the time when mutant powers will slowly begin to kind
of manifest right where the mutant gene will activate somewhere in that time
period. Usually between the ages of like 10, 11,
all the way up to like 14 or 15 years old, right?
Doing that point when the body begins to change,
that's when the meat and gene begins to activate.
And so with that being the case, basically she ends up developing telepathy,
but this telepathy comes by way of her, not really understanding what it is,
but only picking up on the emotional, I guess,
the emotional state of individuals who were coming for them with the intention
of killing them. Now,
the people who are coming for them are the ones who are basically leaving babies
in that burnt place. Right.
Let's just leaving on in that location because there were two strains,
there were two different that kind of a thing.
And that's kind of what's going on here. Why they,
they discovered that there's this group here that's just different and they just
kind of want to kill them. Right? So basically the 1 million year ago,
version of what's going on right now in Marvel comics with regards to the mutant
population, right?
So basically Cubans have been hunting for at least a million years is basically
what Jason Aaron's telling us now with this guy who kind of shows up you're East
called the high Walker.
That's kind of the leader of the Charles Xavier S character.
That's the only real name we're given for him.
He initially tries to use peace and kindness and so on and so forth,
but it doesn't really work what,
instead like their fear begins to override their senses and where you end up
having this young girl who basically begins to realize this is telepathy.
That she's, that she's kind of, uh,
she's basically activating and sorta gets sort of angry and irritated and off,
and doesn't really want to leave. It leads to high Walker,
basically being exposed for a brief moment, only for him to be killed.
And that leads the other mutants jumping in and basically going in, you know,
getting into a fight with all the different humans and all the groups,
basically, you know,
both groups slaughtering each other to the point that this little girl is the
only one left. She's the only one left.
But for her kind of going forward from here,
she realizes that she basically has telepathy right now.
She doesn't quite know what to call it. She's not really sure what it is.
She's somebody just knows.
She can communicate with her mind and pick up on the feelings of others,
the revelation and the realization of what she has and what she's capable of.
Doesn't really come until some future period.
When she basically goes back to the burn place to kind of sacrifice herself to
the vultures. And then in turn, it's possessed by the Phoenix force.
Now this is where I'm not really big on this great, big, huge change.
Not necessarily because I'm against change,
but I'm not one of those common book fans. And just doesn't like it.
When things change, I'm a reading for 20 something years. Believe me,
I'm aware that comics change.
What really kind of baffles me here is it really seems to fly in the face of
everything that made the dark Phoenix saga, what it was the whole,
the whole idea behind the dark Phoenix saga in Marvel comics in the eighties,
when Claremont wrote it, agent was common answer to the question.
What happens if some sort of primordial cosmic entity that's never really known
hatred or anger bonds itself to a human being,
how do they kind of cope in that situation? Jean Gray, basically, you know,
really the Phoenix force becoming Jean Gray,
which is revealed to the end of the dark Phoenix saga. But, but Jean Gray,
you know, being a host for the Phoenix or however you want to slice it,
introduce the Phoenix force to emotions that had never experienced before,
right? Lust, anger, wrath, different things like that.
And the Phoenix didn't really know how to handle it.
And so it basically went insane. Now there are,
there have been instances past where the Phoenix has encountered living beams
and Excalibur volume, one issues 42 through 50.
I think it was that kind of introduced the idea of like net chrom and fare on
and those guys and how like nut basically tricked the Phoenix and to like
creating all these different pillars and things like that.
But the Phoenix wasn't actually bonded to a person instead.
It was the Phoenix being manipulated into doing a thing. But for the most part,
the Phoenix just kind of existed in isolation in space.
And so having an instance where the Phoenix bonds to a young girl here and then
learns all these emotions really kind of [inaudible] question,
did the Phoenix forget when it got to,
when it got to the Phoenix to the dark Phoenix saga, you know,
a million years of memories of just kind of forgot what happened, right? I mean,
I have a hard time believing that a cosmic entity could forget something like
Ali G when I put my phone, you know, it, it doesn't really work that way.
I'm by no means railing against this.
It's just one of these things where I'm trying to find a way to consolidate and
reconcile these two columns. And it doesn't really seem to be a way to do it.
But the idea behind this is that with this girl being possessed by the Phoenix,
that initially rage and vengeance are really what overtake her right rage and
vengeance against like these baseline humans, right?
These normal humans out there that are basically governed by fear that the human
race, because in its earliest days was governed by fear.
It would forever more be governed by fear. And in truth,
that's actually an honest way to look at it, right?
That despite human sentience and things like that,
the most primal basic emotion of humanity is fear.
And times of desperation and times of fear and times of doubt,
people will believe what they want to believe,
even if it doesn't make any sense,
just because of the fact that it gives them some measure of comfort, right?
Humans are always kind of fleeing and trying to find some measure of comfort
regardless of how it may be.
But the important thing is that what she sees here in the base level of humanity
and kind of looking out into the future of what, of what a weight's humanity is,
it's always going to be the same thing, right? Like this,
this fear of things they don't understand is going to govern the very nature of
humanity from now going forward,
as she ponders the idea of just wiping it all away, right?
I've literally just wiping out the entirety of the earth of ending all life on
the planet and then just kind of letting it start over, right?
Because that's kind of what the Phoenix force stops.
The Phoenix force gets rid of things that don't work, why it does that.
I don't know. It's an answer grant Morrison gave us.
And it's one that Marvel never bothered to clarify. So that's it,
that's the only real response that we get.
But the end result of her really ending the entirety of humanity comes by way
of one of the wolves, right? Which basically looks her hand.
And in that moment she kind of experiences,
it kind of brings her back to an era of kindness, right?
Where these wolves could have killed her instead, they took her to race.
And so it's kind of interesting because animals are cool people or are really
cool humans suck like that. That's kind of the perspective she gives us.
PETA would absolutely love this girl.
But the important thing here is that she really kind of backs away, right?
She moves away from this concept. And so at some point in the future,
we're not really given a definitive timeframe that the Phoenix just age this
girl up to basically, you know, basically adulthood,
but she ends up traveling directly to Asgard.
And one of the funniest things that we get is that you have Odin trying to lift
the hammer mule near what you can do,
because this happens after he put the sentience storm inside the hammer.
So the hammer now has a will of its own and just doesn't want to be lifted by
Odin. And so we're all as it's happening.
Something the Phoenix force shows up here and starts laying waste to all the
forces of the, of the as guardians. And when it busts into where Odin's at,
the Phoenix basically says, you can call me the Phoenix, right?
I'm putting a team together to save the world from itself and from people like
you and me, are you in?
So this was really kind of how the Phoenix and Odin first met each other,
which is really kind of a crazy question because the thing that I would ask you
this, this is really the question that I would have to ask is Thor,
really the child of Odin and Gaia or store the child of Phoenix and Odin.
That's my question, because I feel like Jason, Aaron's going to change that.
And if four is actually the child of the Phoenix force, that would enter a,
that would bring in a whole new level of power, it'd be kind of bonkers.
But with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you guys are new here to come and to explain,
to make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the rod core.
If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all there.
Bruce.
[inaudible].